افرد مصادر محاليل الجزيره بانه تامر
كوزات فيما تعرف بقوه السوريه الديمقراطيه
في قريه الطويله بمحافظه تل التمر شمال
الحسكه تعرضت لقصف من الجيش التركي وبحسب
المصادر فان المدفعيه التركيه تستهدفت
ايضا تجمعات اللي ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه على امتداد الطريق الدولي ام
4 في قريه عين عيسى بريف الحسكه كما ذكرت
مصادر الجزيره في المعارضه السوريه
المسلحه ان الطائرات المسيره التركيه قصفت
تحصينات لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في قرن عده في الريف الغربي لمدينه عين
العرب على الحدود السوريه التركيه
في حلب بمعنى مراسل الجزيره عمر الحوراني
مجمل تطورات اليوم عمر
بالفعل كان هناك قصف مدفعي من قبل القوات
التركيه هنا المتمرزه في شمال سوريا
استهدف مواقع لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وتركز قصف
منطقه الطويله بريف الحسكه وايضا كان هناك
قصف استهدف منطقه الام فور في عين همم
عيسى وايضا قصف استهدف قرى في التابعه
لعين العرب وتركز على زور مغار وايضا كان
قصف لمنطقه الشيوخ هناك ايضا كان هناك قصف
بالطائرات المسيره وهذا القصف يشير الى ان
العمليه العسكريه مستمره وبانى خيار
العمليه العسكريه مطروح وانه لم يتم
التوافق حتى الان على خيار بديل والخيار
ياتي من خلال الطرح الروسي الذي
الذي يقول بان هناك قوات للنظام ستحل مكان
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وحتى الان المصدر
الرسمي من قبل ما تعرف في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ما زالت تبدي رفضها لتسليم
المناطق لقوات النظام وانسحاب قواتها عن
المناطق التي تطالب بها تركيا وتركيا مصره
على انسحابها من مناطق وهي عين العرب
ومنبج وتل- رفعت هذه المناطق التضعض تقع
ضمن ال 30 كلم الذي التي تطالب بها تركيا
بانسحاب هذه القوات من هذه لتامين حدودها
كما تقول انقره وهناك مفاوضات مستمره من
همم من قبل روسيا مع همم
انقره
لحيلوله دون عمل عمليه عسكريه هذه العمليه
المستمره منذ العشرين من همم تشرين الثاني
انه نوفمبر من القصف المكثفه الذي يستهدف
مواقع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وبحسب
احصائيات لهذه القوات فان قرابه 220 مدينه
وقريه تم استهدافها بهذا القصف الذي تقوم
به القوات التركيه اما بالقصف المدفعي او
قصف بالطائرات المسيره وايضا الطيران
الحربي كان يشارك بالقصف على هذه المناطق
وما زال الاستعداد العسكري لتركيا قائما
التي ما زالت تضع خيار العمليه العسكريه
البريه على الطاوله اذا ما فشلت المساعي
الروسيه باقناع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
بالانسحاب من المناطق التي تريد تركيا